welcome to this video playing and
baritone hey good score and sis got six
wins two draws no loss that sounds good
okay if I get openings like that I
understand let's know to be very
comfortable for black
okay wait a bit unsure if i should go
age six or not I'm going to play it yeah
of course my plane is a five before in
the long run let's see white very often
booklet Bishop t1n bishop see to trading
that Bishop and then try to go a form
okay that looks really weird I mean it's
not going to play not going to play you
for him okay would be eight would be
nice but he's got the bishop on your
form so maybe this in order to go e five
he's not controlling e5 here which is a
problem five mmm okay maybe he didn't
have anything against it in the first
place so Ruby aight i guess taking this
try to go queen whoa really okay
even f5 is a move to just stop to just
stop everything there let's do that stop
f5
ok so don't really mind that so much do
I go there I think I do and to create
would be too now I will pawn down but
still don't believe this here provide d
50 ever hear that splits true night only
three now it's not so badly placed ok
that's not good now then I played that
far too relaxed I mean it really was bad
for white but you still have to make
some good moves and this isn't any good
25 is a big issue to go 97 if it takes
on PA droopy 895 I think would be to as
good even though i'm not entirely sure
it might be just a bluff ok then see the
key is going for this click a 97
probably have it to anyway 97 yes 94 Sam
some is in this position
mmm not easy at all I go back Nyjah for
super annoying
you
I don't know didn't find them good move
him maybe there is none okay maybe he
I'm attacking at five huh you should be
five
maybe I can somehow survived that yeah I
thought I can tick maybeee through reno
Bishop f5 rookie Sam Bishop e7 night
down now amazing ok Sabby should be 795
Bishop e3 is going for the BS III porn
it's not not so clear maybe we should
see seven is good
you know and also somewhat risky move to
play so if eight maybe time morning yeah
I'm going for the f8 and now this limit
this night and go for III III Andrew
Gough to and then use the King may be
okay somehow it irritated him enough
okay now i can switch back with the rook
pretty pretty annoying ugh now i get
there from home start starts things
start to look up check check check
we difficult for him to stop that porn
without giving me material check check
check we know three mate basically he
doesn't have a check no don't think he
can stop it white resigns well guys I
played that was very lucky win I really
am I played a couple of really strange
moves that I would set up is kind of
weird but I just yeah I played it like I
can do every move and that's not the
case jam after human whose one that
probably somewhere yeah this is this is
no good we should be successes decent
something like that he could have played
93 actually and this is this is really
awkward g5 is hanging this is not
helping wow wow now this part of the
game I really played played badly hear
ya I don't know this is probably just a
bad idea yeah white is what is clearly
better here but somehow it step by step
yeah I think this is the first thing I
think he was probably retailored by this
but I don't think it works or something
like that him I really don't have any
great way to use the second rank him the
computer is agreeing one point something
for what I should take on be aid if I
have to take with the night it's a
really passive and weep on down and
currently my bishop side of doing
anything k mean this is not not bad of
course all night xt5 as possible very
brutal computer move gathered winstead
wind sound right chat on this chicken
that's very convincing up yet it really
am that also should should be good for
him but somehow step-by-step it was
going downhill and it held very passive
there now it's down to zero again and
now better for black yeah the apron yeah
somewhere around here hehe misfolded
like step by step eh for is given by the
stock fish engine just ignoring the rook
that looks very good the rook here is
not going anywhere and why does having
easy ideas here and bishop here the
nights are completely very well very
well coordinated yeah why 20
quite clearly who it was a lucky one
thanks for watching